your new book about face The Odyssey of
an American warrior is co-written by
Julie Sherman a woman why well I had a
lot of people over the 18 years of
rumination I thought thought about
writing this book a lot of authors come
to came to me and asked to write it with
me or for me and I waited for the right
one and Julie Sherman came along and
after looking at her work and talking to
her I concluded that what I really
needed was the a woman's feel a woman's
touch
war is about men and men take life but
the end horrible result about war is it
takes the life of young men in the main
and it's the sons the daughter of the
daughters the husbands of women women
give life and I felt that if we could
discuss war and discuss it with that
man's passion from my own experience but
with the sensitivity and that depth and
feeling of a woman we could tell the
complete story how many times during
that was 18 years since she left the
army did you seriously consider writing
this book Oh probably a half dozen there
were a number of that qualified people
that came to me but I wanted I wanted
also to to ensure that I had my head
together so my the message that I was
going to give would be clear and would
be objective and would be without
bitterness and vindictiveness and the
the need to even the score at the end of
the whole book some 875 pages your last
mine says something about you think
you've got the anger out of your system
when were you the most angry and wiry
angry well in 1971 I said that to the
nation that Vietnam was a bad war and I
said it would from my heart from the
experiences of almost six years over a
six-year period in Vietnam that it was a
bad war we were losing it we were
bleeding unnecessarily and there was
just simply no way we were going to win
it nor our people that we were involved
with the South Vietnamese were going to
win it and we should get out now and
what I didn't realize that when you
sound off against a big institution like
the US Army and say they're all wrong I
didn't realize what happened to
whistleblowers and I got bumped about
the head and shoulders in a very severe
way and that created the bitterness and
that that caused me to leave America
leave my roots and go to us day and be
angry for a long time were you angry at
all before you made those pronouncements
on issues and answers well I certainly
was you know in 1966 I told the army
chief of staff here ok Johnson we were
losing the war in 1968 I wrote in a
paper which went to general Westmoreland
that we'd botched the war the following
year 69 until the Secretary of the army
Stanley Reiser that we were losing the
war and I told anybody and everybody
that that would listen to me I wrote
this in army publications it was a
pretty evident where I was coming from
but nothing was done I took a draftee
battalion full full of untrained kids in
69 and turned him into a praetorian
guard that just turned the battlefield
around and at the end of a five-month
period we'd killed 2,500 enemy at the
loss of 25 of my men a hundred to one
ratio we were fighting the war as the
war should have been fought but no one
listened no general came down and said
gee how did you guys do this how do
these untrained troopers win battles
like this time and time again because we
didn't want to learn that the government
the army specifically has no real deep
reflection they just don't look at the
past to learn from it to grow from it
and I think that's the thing
as it built up this frustration caused
me to sound off you know as a little kid
when I was 15 I was in Italy and General
Eisenhower who is a five-star general
stopped in front of me and probably
because I was just a little 15 year old
kid he said well how do you like it here
son I said oh just fine in general and
he said how's the child you know normal
thing of generals gonna ask a little
glass oh that's terrible
we'd spam every day and he went down the
line and he's why do these guys eat spam
every day but you know went from the
Lieutenant General to the Major General
to down to the little major did a reply
came bubbling up oh the depo from the
war is filled with spam we got to get
rid of it so I said stop it give these
guys you know fresh food and so on
so I've from that point forward as long
as I was a soldier I sounded up if I saw
something wrong I told them so when I
look back I reflect that my sounding off
in 71 I tried it through the system I
told everybody in the army that would
listen to me when I realized that that
wasn't going to happen I went to the
people via the media and told them the
truth of what was happening in Vietnam
what were you doing in the Army when
you're 15 years old I was interested in
sex and adventure and that seemed to be
the army provided both could you get in
the army when you were 15 if you lied
and I had been in the Merchant Marine
for a year before so I had merchants
papers from my experience in the Pacific
and so I used those as the documents to
get me in the army I was an orphan so it
was it was the army became a home for me
Brian
it became a my family something I love
very very much so I was very protective
towards this institution and I always
loved my soldiers because I was a
soldier and I wanted to keep them alive
I believed in winning battles and
fighting wars and I was a warrior but
not at the expense of my men so I think
that great love for my soldiers was the
thing too that made me stand up and and
shout stop the madness
do you think if you were right if you
had written a book I know you talked
about the Korean War in your book and
the
Vietnam where I won't talk about the
Korean War in just a second but if you
basically said the Vietnam War was a
good thing and we did a good job that
you'd be getting the kind of reviews
positive praise for your book that
you're getting well I don't know I would
from certain circles certainly the army
magazine and the institution would
endorse what I have to say but I think
in the book is the truth and I think
that those people who are writing the
reviews most of them had been on the
battlefield had gone through that same
experience as I and there's a seeing
somebody finally coming out in a na in a
real detailed form and offering what
happened in Vietnam and it just wasn't
from Vietnam all this tragedy that
occurred started in 1946 when we took
our officer corps and started this
business of making everybody a diplomat
and a warrior and at which ended up
under Maxwell Taylor when he became
cheapest town our generals became
corporate generals rather than the
fighting generals of the type that won
world war ii the ridgeway's and the
patents and so on you think of metals
metals I mean preface it by saying when
you read about your book and about you
they say you the most decorated man at
the time of your departure from the Army
in 1971 as anybody in the history of the
military or just during the Vietnam War
but I think it's in the hissing history
of the US military what do I think of
medals I think that Napoleon said you
have enough ribbon you can conquer the
world and I think you have to honor your
warriors for standing up and being
counted for moving into the fire across
the killing zone and you honor them with
a piece of ribbon and at the end of
World War two the household name was
Audie Murphy Audie Murphy had what nine
ribbons the Medal of Honor the
Distinguished Service cost the Purple
Heart Silver Star Bronze Star and so on
there were all awards for feats on the
battlefield during the Korean War there
was a fellow right here in Washington DC
named lives now named Scooter Burke
Lloyd Leslie Burke
who won all the medals that Audie Murphy
won he never received any recognition
because that war the Korean War was not
a glorious war we didn't win it it
wasn't there wasn't any berlin's or
tokyo's or so on and the same thing from
the Vietnam War
those kids that won awards for attacking
a machine-gun or saving a comrade were
certainly to be honored and to be
recognized but there were so many others
that were the the self-serving careerist
general officers and Colonels and so on
who used the award thing to get an award
simply to so it looked good on his on
his jacket which would cause someone to
think he was a warrior and you look at
you know that take Admiral Crowe who is
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff on his jacket it's ablaze with
medals and so on 31 of them but there's
not one for a combat deed they're all
having been their awards you're a good
guy award you move some paper across
your desk in a neat way award take
Oliver North who's in the hot seat as we
talk he has 14 awards on his chest but
only three for combat the Silver Star
the Bronze Star and the Purple Heart the
rest are having been their words and he
appears in front of Congress and the
American people think hey this is a
warrior
just like when Admiral Crowe perhaps
appears in front of Congress
those are his credentials and those
congressmen don't know they're just
having been their awards when he says we
need this they believe that he knows
what he's talking about from the
standpoint of being on a battlefield so
I think that we've we've kind of put our
award system at a cross purpose Grenada
there were 7,000 men on that island
they gave 8,000 awards there were 200
enemy Cuban soldiers and so on on that
island and they gave 200 awards for
valor one person enemy soldier so this
is stretching it a bit far Brian I think
we need to go back and clean up our act
on awards and just give awards to
soldiers the final line on awards is to
me the only award that is a today
because it spends considerably
constituted that really means something
to warriors is the Purple Heart and
above that the combat infantry badge
that means I've been there in Vietnam
there were a hundred entry battalions of
that hundred battalions there were 1600
rifle platoons so of the 550,000 men
that fought in Vietnam that were in
Vietnam had served in Vietnam only
50,000 men were infantry out fighting
the enemy and every time they put their
foot down they didn't know whether they
were going to have a foot a leg or life
so I think that we have to look at
medals in the military and in Vietnam
from that viewpoint that it's become a
big corporation rather than a fighting
institution and I think we need to
return on military to an organization
that can serve and defend our country
without all these games people play how
many awards did you win how many ribbons
gee I don't know how many Purple Hearts
eight now that means something to me
what you do the first time you were
wounded and where was it let's see I was
a little kid in Korea I was a squad
leader of an f3 squad and I was flushing
out a sniper and he got me first and of
the bullet struck me in the back of the
head and came came out under the skin of
the back and knocked me on my tail and I
thought it was dead ringing in the ear
and so on and I my buddy that was with
me I was covering me thought I was dead
with blood spurting everywhere and it
may have knocked me out I don't know but
when I when I came to my senses I was by
myself and I crawled out of there I was
way out in front of the enemy lines and
we had just killed three enemy a
machine-gun crew on the way and I - way
to get to this position where I was
firing at the sniper and I had to crawl
over these three fellows and I knew
they'd be alive and I in panic had
dropped my weapon so I I finally crawled
over them and got back to the American
lines and was patched up and back to the
hospital
and I wanted to return because I wanted
to get back to to my unit because it was
my again that point that I brought
earlier it was my family the guys I
really loved there's no bonding like
that on the battlefield that among
combat instrument can you remember and
you don't have to go through this all
these but can you remember the other
seven times when you're wounded as clear
as a bell it's something I don't think
you'd ever forget tell us a couple of
them Oh Jay well I think the one time I
was lying in a position and we were
being shelled and my potential flung his
arm over my back and a shell exploded
right next to us and the Petunia Arjun
said oh I'm hit and and when things
settle down we started what you normally
do is start checking out your body
because things are bumping up against
you dirt and so on and just check out if
you've been wounded and I realized I
hadn't and that's well let's get out
here and grier found that his arm was
nailed to my back and other the shrapnel
had gone through his arm and nailed it
to my back so we had to prise his arm
from my back so that was one that you
know that I wouldn't forget another time
was on in Korea again in 1951 for
November I had a hand grenade blow up
underneath me and it blew me way up in
the air and flung me down on the ground
and tore my arm almost off and and I
thought I was gonna die in a sergeant
named Jack speed from Memphis Tennessee
came running up and he said well the old
man is dead he says and I thought never
am I gonna die on this hill and I got up
enough strength and walked down to where
the doc was patching people up so you
don't forget those experiences and in it
they all kind of happen in slow motion
Brian and you recall the whole thing and
it's something it's like all of us have
been at one time or another in danger of
some sort in an accident with a car you
see that cars swerving over and
everything slowed down and you can see
the other car coming and the thing why
can't I stop and that's the way combat
is I think when it comes to the time
where you
in the utmost danger your whole system
slows down where you're recording every
microsecond of it when do you remember
in your life being the most afraid or
having the most fear well on the
battlefield you're frightened all the
time and you live with it and the beauty
of being a leader are being a squad
leader of platoon sergeant Cudney
commander and so on was you were busy
you're looking after your your troops
shepherding your herd so to speak you
were calling in artillery fire bringing
an error manoeuvring your unit talking
on the radio and you simply didn't have
time to be as concerned as that warrior
is who's just waiting behind a wall for
someone to say let's get up and go so
that's the real problem and another
problem is the brighter you are the more
imagination you have and the more things
your brain can conjure up it's going to
happen to you so if you're a dull foot
and you're not too clever you know you
might make it through the night without
it without a lot of stress I think that
one of the things from Vietnam is this
Vietnam stress syndrome is that those
kids enjoyed something that the American
soldier in the history of our country
from 1776 forward didn't experience in
battle and that was that
minute-to-minute experience of walking
through a field laced with booby traps
that were carefully cama flage you know
that 50% of all casualties in Vietnam
came from mines and booby traps and and
I think that that business if you were
lucky to survive for the 365 days that
our infantry fought in Vietnam that
would sear your mind and and I think
that that is one of the the causes of a
lot of disturbances of among the men
that fought in Vietnam tell our audience
that we're talking about this book right
here about face colonel david hackworth
along with Julie Johnson hi I'm Julie
Sherman I'm sorry how did you write this
book well it took five years Bryant five
long years and and what Julie and I
first did was
worked at a game plan we decided to tape
every experience that I had and that
before the taping this is audio tape
before the taping we took all of the
documents the notebooks the papers the
things I had saved throughout my 25-year
military experience and we'd
compartmentalize that in 18 chapters
well that we assumed we envisioned we
would be writing eighteen chapters and
maybe it was a notebook a little little
small book I'd carried in Korea which
had only six or seven lines in it or a
letter from a friend or a letter that I
had sent home that was saved by my
brother or my sister-in-law or someone
and once we do what once we'd organized
those 18 boxes of of information then we
went through those and recorded those
experiences and then that became a
transcript above this high about 57
tapes worth and then Julie went through
that and set out what the story was and
then she would write a chapter and give
me the chapter I would rewrite the
chapter while she was doing - I would be
doing one and then from that names would
fall out we only started with about
three or four names we ended up with
almost 400 people that contributed to
the book which made the book alive in
that we were drawing on the experiences
on the memories of a lot of other
warriors and so I was like then by the
end of the book driving the truck and
they were 300 odd guys in the back of
the truck whose voices we could use and
I added to the wealth and the knowledge
that's contained in the book and the
accuracy - because your memory is a
funny thing and on the battlefield - you
can only see over the sights your rifle
so you don't see the big picture and we
wanted to tell the big picture as best
we could so then these chapters would go
back and forth and we'd integrate the
input from the letters from the people
that we were tracing down
and we'd crank their stuff into it and
then the thing would be rewrite
rewritten and rewritten and rewritten
some chapters were written 20 times and
so that put a big strain on Julie and I
there's a thing at Julie's a
screenwriter
not a book writer and there's a thing in
her trade called
abandoned you just get so much
information and in my case I was so
passionate about the subject because I
felt the book would cause people to
learn the book would cause people not to
make those horrible mistakes again so I
wanted to get every little detail and so
I might went for example one chapter
which is called the wolf towns which
deals with Korea 1950 and 51 and early
52 when it was completely done locked in
concrete I'd gotten some information
from the National Archives that really
lent a lot of information to that
particular chapter and and I went to
Julie and said look golly this is great
stuff we need to put it in and she felt
that we did reach the point of
abandonment on that chapter and so we
had that kind of friction of
give-and-take friction to get the book
together and get it done correctly and
that's why it took five years which is a
lot of your life or did you write it
where what's worried physically we wrote
it in Australia this was supported by
three or four visits to the United
States by Julie where she went and
interviewed the people that we had
tracked down in their hometown so she
traveled all over America recording
people's comments and collecting data
and so on so we tried to make the book
as complete and accurate as possible
why did Julie have this kind of time is
this a full-time job we made it a
full-time job we decided that it was
such an important message that that you
know the war has changed so
significantly from the time that say my
ancestors came to American 1622 and
landed a James City and they were firing
old musket weapons at that the Indians
and the Indians were fighting firing
bows and Arab arrows back at them
and but by the time I was to leave the
military we had awesome weapons in our
inventory that one alone could bring
about the destruction of humankind
we saw what Chernobyl brought about well
that would if Chernobyl was a bomb that
was on a submarine or an airplane or at
the end of a of a missile it would be a
very small one in what the Soviets and
the Americans and in the English and so
on having their inventories so I felt it
we had to bring out the point that that
that through our story of war is no
longer probably the means to resolve
conflict we got to find a new way to do
it and that's kind of the one of the
bottom lines of the book did you spend
some of their own money to keep this
thing go we sure did and never add the
advance was small because Simon &
Schuster that didn't know us from Adam
we had never written a book before of
any significance and so the advance was
really small and Julie dipped into her
savings and luckily I was retired army
so I had my little magic blue check
coming in every month and that's what
kept us going somewhere I read that you
moved to Australia and became a
millionaire several times over is that
true well Jim Webb said that and I and I
know he worked hard to do his research
you're talking about the pretty amazing
art yeah that's right but I think that's
an era and I'm glad you're going to
correct it to the nation I did do well
but I didn't do well and those kind of
numbers I used my military experience
and my military training which I found
that were very appropriate and
applicable to civilian life if you
thought things out major decisions
rationally and logically it was very
easy to be a success so I used my
military training and running
restaurants and establishing a duck farm
and so on and and I found that civilian
life is a piece of cake why did you come
home well I came a mainly b2b to promote
the book but but I think an important
part of this which I didn't understand
last May my son graduated from school
and I came to his graduation at Berkeley
and at the same time brought the
manuscript back the final manuscript to
Simon & Schuster and then I left there
and went out to Montana to spend a few
days with my best friend and I suddenly
realized that I wanted to come home that
the book had had such a cathartic effect
on me is such a healing effect such a
purging effect that it had taken all of
the bitterness out it had taken all of
the the need to strike out get revenge
for what happened and and I realized
that I wanted to return home and return
to my roots and in this score from that
parade piece I've received hundreds of
letters and many of the people writing
those letters had also read the book
because the the article told about the
book and so many Vietnam veterans so
many wife's the soldiers that were
killed in Vietnam parents of soldiers
who were killed in Vietnam wrote to me
and said that the book had a healing
effect for them and I'm really thrilled
with this that here maybe we've
explained what happened and now two
parents who over all of these years have
thought my god why did my son die and
what were the circumstances and once as
one lieutenant wrote to me said now I
understand I felt so guilty over all of
these years that I was the one who told
men to die and they followed my orders
and I realized that I was fighting in a
in a bad war maybe in an unjust war in a
war that perhaps my country shouldn't
have been in in the first place so I'm
glad that that kind of message is coming
out of it because that's the kind of
effect its had on me Brian
are you home for good you're going to
where you gonna live I think in Montana
or Colorado some someplace up high where
I can be out in the country I like I
like the wilderness and I'm not into the
big cities I've just been in New York
for three or four days I couldn't sleep
through all the noise and because I live
in Austria on top of a little hill all
by myself
and I hear a car coming down the road
they're coming to see me and I don't
hear that many cars coming down the road
so the suddenly to be thrust in New York
City where they're collecting the
garbage at midnight in his crash bang
boom it was like living on a battlefield
so I'll live probably up in the hills
where my family came from I really had
this passion to return to my roots on
the cover of your book and obviously
inside down at the bottom you have with
an introduction by war just who is war
just and why did you ask him to do this
introduction war just as a writer he
wrote for a Newsweek Washington Post
he's now a novelist and a very good one
and we're just had a profound influence
on my life
it started with in June of 1966 during
the Battle of docto Ward was with one of
my platoons the reconnaissance platoon
x' that found themselves in a very tough
firefight deep into enemy positions and
they were surrounded and had a great
number of casualties and ward was
wounded in this action and that night we
couldn't get to the to this disease unit
with infantry to reinforce them we were
working towards that end and they had
the unit had eight seriously wounded men
and who in the terms of the medic that
was on the ground reckoned they wouldn't
make it till first light when we could
get them out with choppers got it all
volunteer Air Force chopper crew that
over the battlefield took a lot of fire
but wench devout and while I thought
that this reporter would come out too
and he refused and he gave up his seat
so a fellow in his judgement who is it
more severely wounded could get out he
stayed on the ground stage surrounded
and so on when he had a free ticket out
which was so typical to reporters in
Vietnam and he won me for life and he
joined the Brotherhood he joined the the
Brotherhood of infantrymen and when the
fight was over I went to the hospital I
word in the combat infantry badge I took
him rifle that we had captured in the
fight a Chinese rifle and he became my
friend for life and then coincidentally
I was from that assignment assigned to
the Pentagon right here in this city and
as was Ward he became the Washington
Post military correspondent so we dealt
a lot together and I learned from him he
wrote his very brilliant book to what
end
and he asked me to review the manuscript
and then I realized the war wasn't only
a war of tactics and strategy but a war
of winning the people to the side of the
government of South Vietnam and there
were so many other political
implications other than the wham-bam
on the battlefield and so would became
my teacher and and and it caused me to
kind of wake up and so that I knew that
he had the sensitivity to to write an
introduction that would really tell what
our book was all about for some reason I
found myself in the MacArthur Museum in
Norfolk Virginia a couple days ago and
saw a film prepared by the museum that
showed General MacArthur during the
Korean War and at one point watching
this they showed the general at Incheon
and the comment voiced over the
something the effect the this was one of
the smartest things that General
MacArthur did in Korea was to land the
troops at Incheon strong it was even
stronger than that you talked about
generals earlier what do you think a
gentle MacArthur
well I think that that there are a lot
of arguments about what happened at
Inchon that me meanwhile back at the
Pusan Perimeter we were getting stronger
and stronger so we were about to break
out anyway and he took an enormous risk
to employ the forces that he did against
the recommendations of the Navy of the
Marine Corps it was a very daring thing
to do and it might have been a desperate
thing to do I think what happened to
General MacArthur was he became a law
unto himself I think that he had
developed to the point where he didn't
have to follow orders and this the thing
about a soldier is you must follow
orders and I think that we experienced
that with MacArthur and a much lower
level we experienced it with Oliver
North his failure to follow the
Constitution his failure to follow the
instructions that he received the law
and it once you go beyond the law when
you've got military forces at your
disposal our only purpose as soldiers is
to defend this country and when you
start doing things on your own you're
violating your charter you talk about in
your own book when you were a soldier
where you would do things beyond I mean
I don't can't remember I read it maybe
there was a Jim Webb piece but where you
would stretch the law or stretch the
rules too I never you know I always
broke the rules okay I was never a
soldier that followed the rules but
there's a difference between breaking
and the army regulation than breaking a
law of our country and violating the
Constitution and that's why when I
became so frustrated over what was
happening in Vietnam
I didn't shred the Constitution I stood
and took the message to the people
because I believed and this was the
thing that hurt me that we were a nation
of the people by the people and for the
people and what our nation was all about
was exactly that and that's the thing
that I found scary that the people were
asleep and the people were not in charge
and they left the run
of our government to the generals to the
politicians to the presidents and so on
and I think that the thing those cats
need us to tell them what to do and if
we think they're in charge
we're making a mistake because this
country should be ran by the people
that's what democracy is all about he
said earlier that the the generals take
their orders from the civilians the
soldier takes his order from the ball I
mean were how can you have a successful
war if the generals aren't running the
show well it's a prerequisite of the
general the guy in charge to ensure that
if he's in a war that he's fighting the
war as effectively as frugally as
brilliant leaves and swiftly as possible
the Col key to war is not a very
complicated thing it's get there first
just with the mostess grab your enemy by
the short of the stock and give him a
punch that he won't forget and make a
real impression on it now when you do
that you've got the initiative on your
side what has happened in our military
is that that since 1946 we become our
generals have removed themselves from
the war they've become as I said earlier
corporate generals they've become people
who are involved in the politics of
things rather than the war of things and
in becoming politicians there they've
developed kind of a go along to get
along attitude and now this is wrong but
what a generals should do if I am your
general and you have tasked me to fight
in Vietnam let's use that situation then
I would say mr. president you realize
the security of our country is not at
stake there why are we fighting there
and you say well we're going to contain
communism there and then I argue that
perhaps we wouldn't be containing
communism there but if you said general
it's my instructions that you will fight
there I say right sir I will deploy my
forces accordingly now I need to fight
there 12 divisions of in
three I'm going to deploy them
simultaneously and I need to destroy the
the port of hype young I need to destroy
the the dykes and the Red River Delta I
need to destroy sanic ville the port I
need to destroy all of the enemy
sanctuaries and the president would say
well we can't allow you to have those
divisions we want to allow you to use
your Navy to blockade and destroy hot
young and then it is my obligation to
say I can't go into that war with these
two mighty fists tied behind my back
if you won't allow me to do it correctly
and to win I quit
find another boy and then I would quit
and you'd find another boy and if he
felt and if we had those kind of
warriors and that's what Ridgeway would
have said and he did say that in 1954
when we are administration was
considering going into that war and that
is what Patton would have said and
that's the kind of generalship we need
we don't need corporate generals we need
warrior generals that know and willing
to stand in the door who are willing to
say that piece of equipment is junk
I mean why today are we spending for
example a half a billion dollars on a
bomber the stealth bomber when they're
not even sure it will fly or why we're
spending hundreds and billions of
dollars on the b-1 bomber and they're
grounded to be used only in war or why
we have tanks and like the lead the
sergeant york divisional and
anti-aircraft system which cost two
billion dollars was quietly folded up
because it didn't work but after the
pack taxpayer had spent that kind of
money so it if you had generals who knew
what the hell they were doing you
wouldn't have these problems so what
we've got to inculcate and what our
Congress has to do and they're at fault
in this whole military procurement thing
too is they've got to insist that we
produce those kind of people and those
are the kind of people that we put stars
on their shoulders that the fighters
from the past not the writers from the
present and the future
what if your president
how do you know that a general has the
right judgment when they come back at
you but what what makes you think that
the president and the civilians don't
have the right answer and they are
ordering the generals to carry out their
mission and if just because the general
comes back and says I'm not going to do
that does that make the general right
well he's got it
the generals simply can't say I won't do
that but they'll give the reasons why
and then and and then they're willing in
the European sense to resign if it's if
it's not done correctly but we we have
developed a system of selection of our
generals that you must have a master's
degree you must have gone to the War
College and have you been to Harvard and
you have you had all of these different
experiences so by the time you are a
general you forgotten what it is to lead
troops and we'll take Westmoreland for
example who I think is a great corporate
general on the battlefield of Europe he
would have probably been another
Eisenhower he's a good man I'm not
saying that he's a bad man but he was
the wrong fellow for that show in
Vietnam but if you take a guy like like
Westmoreland his whole background is one
of an administrator certainly he had the
cursory
I command experiences but he didn't know
what was going on the ground his
background was he was an artilleryman he
had never been in an empty / - nan
intra-company in an infantry battalion
in his life but yet he was the leader of
a war which was purely an infantry war
fought at those levels so he was it was
like a car designer that had never
driven a car and many of our divisions
were commanded in Vietnam by those type
people who simply didn't know their
trait they may have at one time and I
think one of the problems is most of the
generals in Vietnam were the young
Colonels of World War two the best and
the brightest
and by the time there were 23 24 years
old they were a lieutenant-colonel
today a fellow who's 23 years old is a
lieutenant and he'll probably be a
lieutenant for a couple more years so
he's getting a lot of experience at
platoon level Patton said an officer
wasn't worth a pinch of salt until he
had 10 years with troops and but our
soldiers and our officers and leaders
today don't get that kind of experience
I think today right now 1989 the Army
has recognized this now I just been to
the 7th division at the 25th division
and the National Training Center out at
Fort Irwin and I've talked to the young
leaders and these people are good and
the end they and the battalion
commanders that I spoke to had been it
with their battalions a long time and
were eminently qualified and I think
where it happens is once they leave
battalion and they become a bird colonel
or above that's where the corruption
begins and then these are the fellows
who become the generals and and and
they're the ones who go along to get
along and will stand in the door you've
just joined us we're talking with
retired colonel david hackworth
this is his book it's called about-face
The Odyssey of an American warrior
co-authored with Julie
Sherman go back to it let's quickly go
over for those people who have just
joined us your military experience you
came in when you're 15 years old you're
first served in Italy 1946 46 to 50 you
were not in World War two nope came at
the end of World War just as when the
war ended came in as a bit much to dip
you got a battlefield commission where
in Korea what was your first rank on the
battlefield I was a squad leader then a
platoon sergeant and a platoon leader
and then a company commander and I was
trained in trieste in almost a time-warp
it was an isolated command all of the
NCOs were kind of Burt Lancaster From
Here to Eternity kind of guys and
noncommissioned officers and
noncommissioned officers all of the
officers were eminently qualified from
the war combat veterans and so on so I
thought that was what
the army was all about meaning I thought
the whole United States Army was like
Trieste but what what it was
Italy and Trieste in Italy it was called
trust United States troops Trieste
United States troops and when I left
that command I was well trained in the
basics and my platoon side would feed it
into our heads if you don't learn it
right you won't do it right and we
learned it right by repetition by iron
discipline and by great motivation and
great spirit so I took those values and
for the next 21 years imposed them on
any unit that I served in and I was
always in trouble for being too tough
for being too too discipline but I'll
tell you one thing Brian very few of my
soldiers died because I made damn
certain they were well-trained and if
you're going to have an army then that's
their function you got to make certain
they're well-trained if you have
electrical company that that that's
playing with electricity you want to
make damn well sure that all your
electrician's have played with
electricity before I know that if they
touch the wrong thing they're dead how
much formal education you hear seventh
grade at that time seventh grade yes how
about now uh of university degree the
the army was incredibly good to me they
educated me they sent me to university I
went to Austin Peay University in
Tennessee and got a degree in history
and so I'm not just knocking the army in
terms of attacking an institution I have
a great love for this institution
because it it was my home it looked
after me and I just want to make sure
that we never repeat the mistakes of the
past I think the United States Army will
ever fight again in a conventional war
well that's hard to say and that'll have
a crystal ball I don't think that I
don't think you'll see a war between
superpowers I think that both the Soviet
Union the United States realized that
that the destructive power is that that
they they have at the end of their
cannons is so so mind-boggling that it
would destroy that destroy the
countries and to destroy the world if
somebody told it I do think if I just
sure finish that I do think that we will
see wars of national liberation similar
to what we had in Vietnam I think we'll
see wars in Latin America or Latin
America is exploding and I think they
that that is where our strategic
interest is really threatened and I
think that we need forces who know how
to deal with that and more important we
need diplomats right here in your city
who can solve the matter without
conflict who can solve the matter
through programs of education and and
stopping this whole gringo thing of the
of the arrogant yank coming in and and
taking advantage of somebody that
doesn't have the good things that we
have I think that a lot can be done in
Latin America to preclude a war but I
think we've got to be prepared for that
contingency long way in Korea I was
there 1950 51 52 I went to Fort Benning
for in 1952 beginning george'll yeah
just kind of like a mid-level course on
infantry which went from the company to
regiment and then I went back to Korea
52 to 53 halawi in vietnam 65 through
all of 65 or 66 64 to 67 and 69 70s and
half of 71
what did we not learn from Korea or
there's probably better way to ask that
but what mistakes to be making Korea
well that's a very very good question
because in Korea we made a lot of a lot
of mistakes we simply we went there with
the view that well here comes Uncle Sam
we've just kicked the Japs and the
Germans tail and we anybody gets in our
way I was like John Wayne and Top Gun
type thing better stand aside and we
thought our presence which would stop
the North Koreans as we did the same in
Vietnam as we did recently in Lebanon
our presence would would cool things off
and we sent an army that was badly
trained badly led by
of tired old men and badly equipped that
hadn't been trained for the battlefield
and we made a lot of mistakes and things
didn't turn around until we got a leader
Ridgeway and when general Walker was
killed Ridgeway took over and he turned
one in one of the most important events
of military history how one man could
take a defeated army and turn it around
that's why leadership is threaded
through this discussion so much if you
got the right leader you can get the job
done go back to general Ridgway though
and just tell me what you liked about
him as a leader he was on the
battlefield he knew his trade meaning he
knew what to do what the tactics were
about he knew what strategy was about
and he was not afraid afraid to tell the
President of the United States
Truman at that time when things were not
going right did you know him I never
knew him personally but I've admired him
and I served under his command and of
course in the 8th army how many people
did you have command over in Korea in
Korea oh the most would be a rifle
company a couple hundred men and what
technique did you use leadership
technique did you use in Korea that you
can remember that people responded to I
talked to my soldiers I was there I
would never give an order that that that
I wouldn't do myself and and I love my
soldiers I never wasted them they knew
that and we we were formed a very
perfect team I was very hard on him
meaning I was like a father that that
took his children and laid of us a very
disciplined trip on him but we were not
playing in the backyard we were playing
in a life-and-death game and if I could
train them where they were confident and
confident then I knew they could make it
through the night and the most horrible
experience that a human can endure and
that's being an infantryman on the
battlefield when shells are crashing in
booby traps are exploding machine guns
are ripping away so it's it's a it's a
one big raging atrocity Brian based on
what your experience was
did you ever change the way you led
troops after Korea
I always lead from the front and and
that was ridgway's way of leading and
physically go to the front
physically ahead of them oh well I in
the Delta of Vietnam when I took over
battalion that was so badly trained it
was filled with draftees and bad
leadership and so on that I virtually
had to become a squad leader again
meaning I virtually had to lead from the
front as soon as I got him trained up I
got back to where I could command you
know you really can't fight a battalion
or a brigade by playing squad leader you
got to get back and look at the battle
and see it see it from an overview point
but there's always a time that you've
got to go and understand the pulse of it
you just got to grab on to the pulse of
the fight and to find out what's going
on the great generals of history but the
Jacksons and the Rommels and the
ridgway's and the Gavin's and so on
where guys who lead from the front
not from their helicopter as was in
Vietnam
or not from the command and control
bunker that's in the Pentagon they were
there and they knew what was going on
and they had a good feel for the war
another man who was outspoken in Vietnam
who has been now the subject of another
very successful book Neill shins bright
shining light John Paul van got out as a
lieutenant colonel came back as a Major
General in their civilian life very well
came well here's my company commander in
Korea for a while and I worked with him
in the Delta and I as a guy I admired a
great deal why he was one of the kind of
guys that we're talking about he wasn't
afraid to stand up and tell the truth he
flew around one of those planes oh yeah
but wet that's when he was killed and I
flew around one of those planes too but
I wasn't reluctant to land a damn thing
and get on the ground and lead my troops
nor was John Paul van he was a doer a
shaker and a maker and I liked him and I
thought he's a good man Neil Sheehan
gives you a mixed picture though I'm
well Neil Sheehan goes into his personal
background and I don't know if I cared
for all of that but I didn't write the
book that's up for - Neil Sheehan
to say what the he had to say but I
think that I enjoyed the book very much
and I think that our book certainly
dovetails very neatly with it as a
companion piece because we're talking
about the war from the standpoint of the
u.s. where that was the Vietnamese side
even though we have one strong chapter
that deals with Arvind and the
Vietnamese and for my almost two plus
years experience working as an advisor
at Brigade and division and Special Zone
level in Vietnam with the Vietnamese you
what do you think men in the military in
a war situation respond to the best
personal relationship tough vs. loud
versus quiet all those little things
that people study when it comes to
leadership what was your style you
scream and yell at them no I don't think
you're a lot done by screaming and
yelling I think that by setting the
example by winning their confidence
letting them know that you're not a
butcher that you love them that you're
going to care for them and and that you
really know your trade and unless your
soldiers know that ok and I'll give you
a good story that that that's told and
about faces as I taken over this
battalion this is when I described of
draftees on the first day and I just
couldn't believe their condition of this
unit was just total disintegration and I
reckoned that their defensive positions
wouldn't hack if they we were tapped at
the enemy hit us we'd we'd be in serious
trouble so my first order after taking
over the unit was by midnight I want us
to be fall fall back 300 yards I want
new positions dug and and I want all
this junk taken out there was there was
a coax and and soft drinks and little
containers on position the men slept in
cots
that the weapons were rusty ammunition
was in the mud it was just simply not a
professional military organization it
was an organization that had been
blooded for six months and they were
just waiting for disaster so I fell them
back they dug into know and the new
holes got the new positions together
with a lot of grumbling who is this new
guy that Gaea they would call me GI Joe
who's going to change this thing around
and blow our nice soft life apart and
the exactly at midnight that night as if
I would have planned that we got hit
with everything that the enemy could
throw at us with rockets and with
artillery fire of all sorts and the men
went to the defensive position and I had
been away from troops from combat troops
okay I had a battalion at Fort Lewis
just before I came to Vietnam on this
tour but I'd been away from the war for
a couple years and I was nervous as
Nellie you know I was grabbed a rifle
geez I hope I don't blow this thing
here's with all my combat experience he
could imagine these dilettante that came
in who hadn't been with troops for 10 or
15 years and took a battalion okay oh
and as I was a adjusting artillery and
calling in air and getting flare ships
and all these good things you do and
under those circumstances a young
lieutenant ran by to go into his
fighting position and he said I'll tell
you what he's a mean son of a [ __ ] but
he knows what he's doing and that that
was success and that yeah and the next
day the grumbling slowed down and that
those words were probably spread
throughout the battalion that I knew
what I was doing and if we had more
people in Vietnam that knew what they
were doing I think the outcome of that
war at the tactical level on the
battlefield would have been a lot
different we will come out with with
real honor rather than the kissinger
peace with honor meaning where we sold
on our allies if you had to pick a
general that's in the United States Army
today that's your kind of general you
got anyway I got lots of them aim a
couple oh sure there's Jim muscleman
Johnny Howard Jim Bucky Alma
kids that I do or young lieutenants
young majors and so on
Don Hilbert right here in your city
they've got a lot of very confident guys
I'm very pleased with the number of the
generals that I know that I've soldiered
with Glenn Mallory I could and I could
name probably a dozen so I think I think
that somebody who's pickin generals are
picking the kind of guys who will stand
in the door and who'll give us who bring
back that warrior leaders spirit that we
had in this country before the patents
in the ridgeway's back in 1971 he went
on issues and answers to say had you
plan to say the strong things about the
Vietnam War that you did well I had a
lot of time to ruminate about it and it
was a hell of a decision because I knew
I was cutting my throat in terms of the
military I knew I was all washed up if I
sound it off but I felt it was necessary
that I did and so I did my homework and
I meaning I knew I was going to talk
about training I was going to talk about
Vietnamization I was going to talk about
how the war was being fought about the
bad senior leadership and so when it
came to to filming it I had my act
together where'd you do it right in
Vietnam in the Mekong Delta you remember
who interviewed you yeah guy named
Howard Tucker from ABC and his Nick
George who was the ABC girl chief who
later and Nick George is very
responsible for I think probably keeping
me alive because the army became
immediately angry and a lot of funny
things happened to me and Nick George
too simply assigned a camera team and
Anna and a narrator to me and wherever I
went along with this ABC team and I had
the power of the press it was a great
insurance policy in my back pocket did
they know when they assigned the crew T
that you were going to sound off oh well
the ABC people had been
asking me for about three months to do
this interview and I was trying to weigh
up whether I wanted to pay the price or
go to war college and get a star and go
onward and upwards how did they know by
the way that you were even controversial
or just wrote a book called military men
if you remember that book and there was
a chapter in there called the colonel it
didn't mention me by name but and he
tried to shape me so you couldn't like
he made me five foot nine and and
changed my appearance a bit and so on
but among the media they knew that that
was david hackworth so and they knew
those words were mine and they could
feel the anger and what they were trying
to do is get me to be the first senior
guide to sound off and in retrospect I'm
glad I did it I'm sure that I caused us
to get out of that mess a little bit
earlier minute left what's been the
reaction to the to the by the military
to this book and has anybody not liked
it and come and told you so the reaction
to the military the current military
that's running things right in your town
has been very favorable they allowed me
first of all general Bagnall commanders
the Western a command out in the Pacific
invited me out there to talk on my
Vietnam experience to talk about how to
fight the guerrilla to his commanders
and staff I visited the 25th division
the seventh division by invitation of
their commanders I visited the National
Training Center so I think that the I
I'm actually rather surprised that
they're letting somebody who had once
gave them a good blast in the know is
back but I think that they think that
there are some good lessons learned in
this book and they can learn something
for me so they've forgiven me and I've
forgiven them and remember
and I've forgiven them and remember the
guys running the artery today weren't
the generals in Vietnam they were the
majors who were mumbling and grumbling
and bitching and moaning just like I was
they knew the truth the book about face
the Odyssey of an American warrior
Colonel David H hackers US Army retired
and Julie Sherman thank you very much
for your time my pleasure